okay what is up there reject nation all
right it's 7 37 p.m right now we've been
shooting a whole bunch of videos i got
uh i got blown up on my twitter with a
whole bunch of message requests
apparently john campia my friend john
campia i should text him about this yeah
or i should just put out this video and
see if he texts me first yeah you should
ask why he didn't text you this year
yeah what the heck don't you know we do
can't beat this
so basically i got a whole bunch of
message requests like did you see what
john campio put out the photos that he
put out what do you think right now
because it's message request everything
is only screenshot this everything says
this media is hidden this is how we do
reaction to the photos when we get
message requests i let it be hidden and
then i pull it up real time i'm going to
go off hayden howell shouts out to you
hayden haley just got a shout out here
so there's two photos here i'm gonna
have to
put them on the computer eventually to
let john see them so i'm gonna assume
you know what just describe them to me
and i'll react to that all right i'm
gonna look at the first photo right now
there's two and then well let's see what
john campbell has to say after let's see
all right guys look i'm hyperparanoid
because i can't tell if these are real
or fake i've been asking around to try
to find out so they're only going to
flash up on screen like a couple times
throughout this video just to be safe
but still it's it's an enjoyable video
so keep watching
oh [ __ ]
is that real
hello
let me put it on the computer
i'm so sorry let me put another computer
for an air drop you're pretty wide over
it is such a process dude is this real
oh it could be from that one scene that
tom holland was talking about the dinner
scene where they have an intimate
discussion with somebody important yes
oh awesome that's exactly that's 100
what i was talking about
he's been out there talking about that
okay here we go all right
okay so yeah because you have wow having
the intimate dinner scene charlie cox
said the hair does look a little bit
different than how we last saw him in
daredevil season three variant you just
could be a variant
oh a dude i mean it could be that scene
right i mean it's not a dinner because
they don't have much food on the table
they just have tea and documents but
still it could be because charlie cox
could be put in this photo sure it could
be a photoshop in there if anything but
i don't recall any images of seeing like
happy that's a very specific type of
image we're happy to have the chair be
in the position it's in to have his arms
on there to be looking at uh matt
murdock and like this
everything around here looks new to me
it's just the one part that's suspicious
is is that a real image of charlie cox
or is it toby mcguire with a charlie
cock's head pasted on top and a cane
added in maybe it could be maybe
trust nothing anymore then we got a
second one to look at here from hayden
powell media is hidden all right one two
and three
what no way
that's the reaction of the day
what this is oh come on i can't tell
i can't tell
is that real trust your gut it must be
real trust your gut
i don't know here let me air drop it to
the computer
john look away i'm not looking at
nothing g all right three two one and i
could have sent this off from the
computer uh there's twitter on the
computer that's how we've always done it
for some reason
right way more fun yeah i get a preview
i get to anticipate what you're reacting
to and then finally i see it that's
great
look at that it's toby andrew and tom we
gotta zoom oh my
the oh man i can't tell this picture
looks faker than the first picture it
definitely looks more famous that's a
very specific haircut for toby mcguire
does that match up with how toby
maguire's hair has been maybe he's had
shorter hair lately i saw a picture of
him at a party with little nas x you
said little nas yeah this is like a
halloween party i guess that profile
wise
yeah profile wise it could be it maybe i
just can't tell well and it's also been
a few months since they shot this so
maybe his hair has changed a little bit
but it is shorter than you was before
why would camp you put these out he's
like so much more in the studios than we
are let's go to his so that makes it
gets me wondering i'm like did they give
him these to leak yeah yeah is this an
orchestrated leak you know stranger
things happen these days he's got a
three-part thread here oh holy [ __ ] okay
so i've shared spider-man photoshops
before like with 12k retweets like this
one and today i got sent these and
they're also great photoshops because
the one image has a classic mistake of
having inconsistent placement okay
of the light source in the image the
light source is on the left side of tom
and andrew's face and on the wrong side
of toby's obviously photoshop
five minutes later someone contacts me
saying they might be real so just to be
safe i delete them go eat dinner watch
some of the football game then turn on
my computer and find out the damn thing
went viral and i'm trending on twitter
so yeah i thought and still think
they're fake just like this one but who
knows you decide okay uh one if i
thought the images were real and two
wanted to share them i would have done a
headline video on my channel to get
views not on twitter just to delete it
five minutes later
really i don't
know i don't know man you just throwing
up a smoke screen campia in all fairness
if i talk to john and then he can't be
and if he tells me that there if he says
anything remotely along the lines of
these are photoshops or these are or
this is i would keep that conversation
100 private i wouldn't i wouldn't who
knows
guys i betrayed the trust of my
friendship to go tell everyone that
they're
so i guess we gotta take campia's word
for it but he did delete them because he
got a little bit suspicious that they
might actually be real so who knows so
let's put them up ourselves but i will
say like they're cool photos but i mean
charlie cox looks like it could be fake
and but the but it's a all it's all
that's so surrounding charlie cox i'm a
little bit suspicious so it does look
like cutouts
honestly they do the tobey mcguire
andrew garfield especially look like cut
outs and i'm trying to read what he's
saying about the lighting because i like
you know it's like you can see there's
some light on like the right side of
each of their faces toby's face and more
forward like it's
it is a bit uncanny because now i'm
sitting here looking at the lights in
the shadows and being like oh i kind of
look motivated from the same
sources but i just it does look way more
cut out than the other one though yeah i
guess i'm gonna take campya's word for
it and say that it's probably fake if
anything the charlie coxswain looks a
little bit more real to me but that one
looks much more could be the scene from
talking about being superheroes but [ __ ]
um okay who knows we get a copyright
sorry then we know it's real if the
channel gets shut down yeah no no it's
real it's just like call champion and be
like i need more guest spots
gotta make up for help me out man give
me more guest spots on your show please
please man back to 900k
all right guys well what do you think do
you think these are real do you think
they're fake subscribe hit that like
button click the notification bell we
might as well do a patron of the day
shout out
lance door you know why i chose you
today because you
remind me of a really buff jacob battle
on and hey he's gonna need a stunt
double when it comes time to make the
inevitable turn into being hobgoblin
that's definitely gonna happen in
spider-man no way home and i mean the
man has been getting fit you could show
him a thing or two you could bring your
fire fighting expertise to the big
screen lance door and you would do it
with authenticity no photoshop there on
those abs or muscles or biceps or
anything
i feel safer just thinking about you
lance so uh be well and we'll catch you
on the next one mwah
[Music]
you